America's top Diplomat but president Xi
Jinping during a visit that Beijing
hopes will reverse what it described as
the downward spiral in ties Anthony
blinken is the first U.S Secretary of
State to meet the Chinese leader in five
years yes you are I hope that through
this visit you'll make a more positive
contributions to stabilizing U.S China
relations
China described the relations between
Washington and Beijing as reaching an
all-time low in a media conference
Lincoln said positive problem-solving
steps were taken the progress would take
time my open expectation is we will have
better Communications better engagement
going forward that's certainly not going
to solve every problem between us far
from it but
it is critical to doing what we both
agree is necessary
and that is responsibly managing the
relationship earlier Lincoln met top
Diplomat Wang Yi who blamed tensions on
wrong American perceptions of China and
urged Washington to stop hyping what he
called the China threat to lift what
Beijing describes as unilateral
sanctions and to respect China's claims
to Taiwan Lincoln says there was no
change to the US's One China policy and
it does not support the Island's
Independence though he raised concerns
over provocative actions by The People's
Liberation Army in the Taiwan Strait on
technology restrictions Lincoln defended
controls as necessary for protecting
National Security and denied Chinese
allegations that the U.S is trying to
contain China's growth
and regarding the Ukraine war he
welcomed beijing's efforts to end the
conflict and pointed to assurances it
would not provide Moscow with lethal Aid
China has however maintained its
economic and diplomatic support of
Russia the tone from both Lincoln and
Beijing has been fairly positive with
both sides straining to find Common
Ground however few agreements were made
and one key disappointment was the
failure to revive military communication
lines cut and former U.S House speaker
Nancy Pelosi visited Taiwan in August
but there were some wins plans for a
working group to stem the tide of the
highly addictive drug fentanyl as well
as an increase in commercial flights and
people-to-people exchanges some analysts
say it's a starting point the simple
fact that two significant influential
figures from both governments get
together and have a marathon discussion
of many many hours is an achievement in
and of itself dialogue discussion
meetings that's the important thing
foreign minister qingang has agreed to a
future visit to the U.S and discussions
are underway for president XI and Joe
Biden to meet later this year katrinau
Al Jazeera Beijing